all right guys bang-bang
I've got Alexis here basically the
president of the internet I think based
on that what some folks were ever
elected I was never elected they're
teasing because of a Forbes article from
way back where they said mayor of the
Internet mayor it's better be the
president not president just just a
humble mayor of the Internet I love it
let's let's just jump in to the
background obviously I think people in
tech know the story of Reddit and all
that but lots of people listening don't
know that story so maybe let's start
with kind of where you grew up and had
to get to Reddit sure I mean I was a
there was a history major at the
University of Virginia back in 2005 and
I was getting ready I was taking the
LSAT actually and I walked out 30
minutes into it because I was hungry for
waffles and I went to the Waffle House
on Route 29 in Charlottesville Virginia
was sitting there eating my waffles
instead of taking the LSAT and I
realized I should probably not be a
lawyer and and with that realized that
needed to do something and and started
kicking around some ideas I'd had for
starting a company and convinced my
roommate to quit his job in order to
come work with me for some indefinite
period of time working on some
ill-defined thing without any sources of
real revenue guaranteed we were gonna
like consult on the side I I managed to
convince him his mom was pissed but I
convinced him to turn down the job offer
and then we were lucky enough to be in
Boston on our senior year Spring Break
while everyone else was going down to
Mexico we went to go hear Paul Graham
give a talk called how to start a
startup and Paul Graham would go on to
start Y Combinator and invited us
basically you know we approached him
after that talk and said hey I want to
pitch you on this idea we came all the
way up from Virginia and he said sure
and he met us for coffee pitched him on
this idea it was a way to order food
from your phone it was 2005 but the
whole idea is you'd skip the line but
you don't have a smart phone in 2005 you
just had text messaging and it was it
was a lot of ugly hacks but
he saw enough potential to then launch y
combinator encouraged us to apply we got
rejected which sucked cuz he just had a
great conversation with him and then the
next morning he called back and and I
was like Hello and he's like look we
still don't like your idea and I'm like
dude why did you call me back to say
that like that's not that's not helpful
at all and he said but we'd like you to
and if you're willing to change your
idea will fund you and I was like I need
to think about that because you got to
play it cool in that situation I was
like okay I'll call you back and we were
convinced we were like somewhere in
Connecticut we got off the train we got
rid of the old idea which was called my
mobile menu or mmm and and call them
back and I was like we will accept your
offer and back then it was it was
$12,000 was how much YC gave you to
start a company in 2005 which was
amazing for us and we got to work and
that is what became reddit in that first
meeting when we took the check Paul said
don't build anything that involves a
phone right now and he was right about
that it was too early but he said build
something in a browser that solves your
problem every day and he said what do
you do every day and and for me it was
I'd open Firefox which was a big deal
open a bunch of tabs and and just read a
ton of different content and and that
wasn't very efficient and and he
actually asked this yes this if we had
ever used delicious and this was a
social bookmarking site basically
Pinterest without pictures if yahoo
acquired them pretty early was all
text-based very programmer focused but
it was people bookmarking interesting
links and so back then it was like tips
for Ruby on Rails and and those would
get bookmarked and the most popular
bookmarks would surface on a page called
delicious slash popular and that was we
had never used it before and he said
take a look at this and he was like what
do you think about this and we were like
oh that's kind of interesting like maybe
there's a there's a there there we know
opening starting your day with a bunch
of tabs wasn't the right move and there
could not be a front page for the
internet in the way that there was a
front page of say the New York Times and
that was something I give credit
Paul for phrasing he was like that's it
he crystallized on it build the front
page of the Internet
he screwed a lot of other things up like
he tried to talk me out of the name and
the mascot I'm commenting but thankfully
we didn't listen to those those tidbits
but but he nailed it with front page of
the Internet that's what we sought out
to build in 2005 we sold it in 2006 to
come and ask which at the time felt like
I was winning the lottery like we were
working for 16 months and it was a 10
million dollar exit which was
life-changing it was more money than my
parents made their entire lives and I
worked for 16 months on this thing like
in my underwear like that's that's
broken but but in 2006 we just didn't
know we didn't have the advisors this
was the impetus for Gary and I had to do
initialised was to be the early stage
investors that we wished we had had when
we were in the trenches so that we could
avoid a lot of those or founders future
founders could avoid the mistakes we
made you know I went on I I wrote a book
I helped launch Hipmunk I was a partner
Y Combinator and then started
initialized with Gary to do this kind of
early stage investing and and then got
the chance to come back to Reddit in
2014 when it was in pretty dire straits
as executive chairman and helped lead
the turnaround for the next like three
years four years and you know reddits
going on to raise funding hundreds of
employees doing really well now and I
moved back into the board roll a board
only role so I could go back to
initialise full-time which is what I'm
doing today so that's my life in I love
it most people don't know this I don't
even think you know this we are actually
small investors but investors through an
SP be in in reddit when you guys did the
turnaround
oh great the first outside big big fan
but in terms of when you the Conde Nast
and when you guys sold the company the
first time I think this is like a
classic situation where founders are
like holy [ __ ] I built this thing and
somebody's gonna buy from me like how
dumb are they it was just it was stupid
and we didn't I mean I cannot stress
this enough and I've never really told
this stuff
publicly it was you know every startup
is dysfunctional in its own way there's
always a million fires and and you're
always just sort of triaging and
prioritizing best you can and we were
not far into reddit's life and we
launched it in June and then less than a
year later I remember in April because
my birthday is in April I was I was in
touch with the head of BD business
development for common tasks this guy
Karoshi Karim Connie who had reached out
because we had a mutual friend who said
hey you should check out this reddit
thing and and he was making overtures
about potentially working together an
acquisition and and at the time we just
weren't we weren't making any progress
shipping new features the site was just
still growing kind of miraculously and
and and overall like the advice we were
getting from our investors was oh my god
that could be an acquisition offer like
go pursue it and and I was basically
told like your best bet alexis is to get
this company sold and I mean we we had
not raised much money at all after YC
demo day we raised 70 grand I think 60
grand so we we we thought that was a ton
we actually turned down an offer to
raise I guess it would be a seed round
of a million dollars back in O five
after demo day we turned it down because
we said we don't need that much money
because we weren't even thinking about
like hiring people it was so dumb and
and so we didn't have much money but it
was fine our burn rate was super low and
and we were not doing any of the right
things to actually grow a business and
here was this offer our investor
explicitly was like Alexis go try to get
get anything you can I was actually able
to reach out to and eventually we worked
our way up at WP and I so Washington
Post Newsweek interactive and we
actually got really close to an
acquisition offer by them but they would
not match Condon asks exorbitant price
and and so we ended up going with condé
and and yeah it seems bonkers to me for
sixteen months worth of work for a
company that really wasn't shipping any
code for the last few months
would would be able to get acquired but
they saw potential credit to like Stevie
Newhouse Karoshi
the ones who ultimately did the deal
kind of asked like they saw the
potential even when we the founders who
were closest to it didn't and you know
kudos I mean I'm I'm grateful that I got
a second chance
and a lot of founders who sell early
don't get that so I know I can I'm very
very grateful for that but this is
exactly the kind of thing we we want to
help founders with during these early
days that we just didn't get when Gary
and I were starting yeah at some point
did you have almost like sellers remorse
like what when did it hit you you're
like [ __ ] we might not we maybe we
should have done that so no yes and no
like my rational brain probably by 2010
or 11 once so I stepped away in 2010
February of 2010 and I went to go went
to go to Armenia went to go to the
motherland to go volunteer for Kiva for
a few months and and around that point I
just thought you know what like all
things considered this the site keeps
growing and it's probably worth more
today than it was back then and then it
really clicked by like 2012 where I was
like oh my god this thing is still
growing and like nothing has changed
like there's no business especially in
tech that should be able to get away
with not evolving and yet it did I read
it didn't have a mobile app until 2015
we launched the mobile app and it was a
big like it was steering the Titanic
over to make mobile a priority whether
it was mobile web or Android iOS but we
did it and and it was like credits all
the folks who got it done but hey once I
realized that like wow this thing just
kept growing cuz the community because
we got just enough right in the product
just enough right and then the community
really did everything to sustain and
grow it that's when I was like oh geez
wow that we really messed this up but my
my my rationale that rational brain
usually gets drowned out by the I guess
it's the more rational or the more stoic
part of my brain which is like look
everything you've had from this point of
selling it happened because you sold it
them and so look at all the amazing
doors that open to you look at all the
amazing things that happen to you and
yeah it'd be a different timeline but
like I'm pretty pretty happy with with
Hassocks are quite happy with how things
are and so I've just tried to look
forward from it and obviously learn from
it and know that it was a mistake but
not dwell not dwell on it I just I've
I've tried to always live my life
looking forward that way to the best of
my ability and so I think part of its
just being delusional but uh just trying
to have that 24-hour memory and and keep
going forward makes it fun would you be
Gary I met Gary when he applied to Y
Combinator in 2008 or nine
he was applying with his company
Posterous which was so back then it was
a marvel because he didn't really have
smart feet and have smart phones I don't
think that order you were just starting
to and so you had phones with these
really good cameras on them but it was a
pain in the butt to get the photos off
and or there was no App Store that's
what it was yes so there's no App Store
really developed yet no ecosystem for
that and it was just coming on and so
you could easily take a bunch of photos
and then email them to an address an
email address and magically a photo blog
would appear it was really clever
software I gave him a thumbs up so he
continued into IC and and then he became
a founder while I was a kind of advisor
there and and then within a couple years
he had sold to Twitter and was back at
YC as a partner and then I was sort of
back in the orbit as like a part-time
partner and then eventually a partner at
YC and you know I ultimately I I could
have been a partner sooner at YC and
Paul Jessica very graciously offered but
I think you'll appreciate this I said I
didn't want to leave New York and like I
just didn't want to be in the Bay Area
for for that extended period of time now
here I am in Florida so I you know I
still I got I got
out of the city but but my heart is
still very much he's coast at least and
I I spent time working alongside Gary
and a bunch of the other partners
working with you know accepting and then
supporting YC companies for a number of
matches and was just left it was just
was floored by how decent and thoughtful
Gary was as well as bright and
hardworking and all those other things
but like incredibly decent and
thoughtful and how much great founders
gravitated to that especially in the Bay
Area where there's just so much [ __ ]
and and I actually think it is it's such
a super power not just because it is
rare which already makes it valuable but
also because it attracts the right kind
of founders and and it's provided us
this amazing orbit of just high-quality
just great individuals that we get to
help build companies with yeah when you
guys decided that you were gonna go and
start initialize and kind of invest
together outside of YC what was that
conversation like did one of you kind of
proposed to the other one or like asking
out on a first date or what was that
like you know it was it was not very
deliberate we were we were both so all
the YC partners at the time and I think
still is they were angel investing so
like you know they write a small check
to the companies that did a batch they
liked and we were doing this we were
doing it pretty well and someone
approached I think it was Gary her
actually might have been hard and said
hey would you take like my money to
invest in addition to your own and and
we were like huh it was like yeah like
you can write pretty small checks no
offense cuz you know
yes sold so early but like if you if you
take other people's money you can write
bigger checks and and start to have even
more of an impact helping these
companies and and maybe even build
something greater than just you all
angel investing and and then I thought
we must have been having drinks one
night or something and it came up and
and I I said yeah that sounds great
what a good deal
and really the first two funds have
initialized were basically just an
extension of our angel investing and it
wasn't until fund three which we
launched in 14 or 15 that it was like
formalized like okay we're gonna take
real institutional money we're gonna we
have this team we're gonna build
software to actually run the firm and
really do it like deliberately sort of
modern initialized as I call it
I didn't start until then yeah I always
love the that's which for that decision
to go from hey I took like my friends
money to the institution's a whole
different ballgame and I think that
there's a lot of fund managers that
don't build the software they don't
build the systems and then they're like
wait a minute you want a report like
every quarter and you like to know how
much money you have yes it gets real
yeah and and I feel like we have such an
inherent advantage just because as
founders we are products people and so
we're I mean even at this day only a few
years in we'll look at anything that
comes up that we have to do that is
repetitive that is sort of tedious and
that becomes top of mind on the product
roadmap for things that we can either
automate or build software to do so that
we can better spend our time and our
team's time doing the things that humans
are really good at so that we let the
software do the the other stuff and it's
not like it's a black box where it's
like tell us to invest it's like
remember all these things it's like
manage the deal flow generate the
reports like this is tedious work that
humans suck at the humans shouldn't be
doing and if a partner wastes a minute
of her day doing like that's a minute
that's not helping the firm actually
make money and that's that's what we
want software doing yeah makes it kind
of sense what am what makes kind of the
partnership work I think a lot of people
realize like you Gary some of the other
partners like you guys are very
supportive of each other both publicly
and obviously seem to have a very strong
relationship bromance
you're referring to the the bromance
it's like what makes that work what
makes the bromance work well you know
hard conversations
being able to and this is the thing this
is why we're so long on coaching
generally executive coaching I mean
everything coaching therapy like all
things exercise of the mind and
relationships something we try to
prioritize and really speak and live
those truths ourselves I mean as well as
physically to that maintenance mentally
and physically is so important and a big
part of that isn't just personal it's
also interpersonal and it takes work
just like any relationship takes work
whether it's romantic or professional
like that it's it's an investment we
have two on two sessions Gary and I do
with our coaches regularly at least
quarterly just to review all the other
mini sort of one-on-ones that Gary and I
try to regularly have and as well as
one-on-ones with our respective coaches
and so one it's acknowledging that it's
all a work in progress and I think the
the big takeaway that we look for in
founders now and really push them on
early early early is so you have to have
the complementary skill set and that's
the tried-and-true like of course yeah
this founder does this this one is that
we're complementary but the the next
level of that in questioning is is
actually looking for where or how much
the Venn diagram overlaps when it comes
to things like values and worldview and
and that is a thing where I've I've had
founder relationships I've been very
close to a lot of found relationships
and portfolio companies where you see
that breakdown on the long term values
and and that that starts to I think that
is the core problem that that only
services later during the harder times
and you know during the early times the
good times growth solves all problems
you know really doesn't really come up
but the hard times when they come up
when they and they always will is what
services when there's those value
worldview differences and it's not to
say one is better or worse but if you
don't have alignment on those things
that matter I think that is where a lot
of the tension like that's where things
start to tear and so I'm fortunate
because
gary and i both see the world as plus
some we don't think that someone else's
success means less success for us we
don't have that zero-sum mentality we
try to espouse that within the
partnership I think the people we've
been able to attract who want to be here
have that and we've tried to orient the
org toward not a bunch of lone wolves
which is the standard VC idea
but actually a Wolfpack because that's
how wolves are supposed to be anyway but
but really using software to be a means
to have that collaboration happen so you
aren't getting information hoarding
you're getting information sharing so
whether a company is doing well or
poorly and again most come I mean all
companies have problems all of the time
what's important is that they're good at
triaging the most important ones as fast
as possible and so we need a culture of
information sharing because there's
someone on the team who can actually
help that company with that problem or
someone they know who can help and we
need as much that to flow as possible it
needs to start from us and I think that
begins with a plus some mindset of like
like we're all economically linked
within the firm but more broadly like we
need to be looking at every opportunity
as something where we can grow and learn
from and have an addition to this this
kind of growth mindset and then also
know that we are more effective as a
team then than anyone of us even Gary or
I could be alone and and software
frankly helps dictate a lot of that
culture just because it is so
transparent all of our updates are seen
by everyone you could see my meeting
notes I just got off the phone with a
reporter my notes from the meeting are
in there they're tagged it's all
structured data you can see the
companies that I talked about you can
see the trends that she's interested in
like that lives there for anyone to see
and and like I don't want to hoard that
I've been I've seen environments where
I'm just like why are we hoarding this
information like this is not like some
reporters email address is not sacred
like no like why are you hoarding this
as if it's like you're precious like oh
no like we're better off the more
yeah and I think a lot of this is
philosophy right in terms of like
literally you go into organizations that
I've seen it especially the older
organizations and the people just their
philosophy is I have my fiefdom and
you're not in it and therefore if I let
you in then I would lose and you're
gonna win or you're gonna take my
business or whatever and so how do you
guys kind of one fight back against that
and then also to how do you structure
the team itself in order to kind of
encourage the collaboration openness and
that communication that's needed to
prevent it I mean we're still figuring a
lot of this stuff out we we want to show
I I think we very much want to lead by
example and so a lot of this I mean we
actually have an internal leader board
which tracks very competitive which
tracks folio notes across the different
items and and I make it's my personal
goal to always be number one there and
and Gary and I are always fighting it
out but but I want to demonstrate to the
org that like we like we expect to be
using this thing as much or more than
everyone here like we this isn't a
scenario where we as founders of the
firm are above like leaving meeting
notes like on the contrary this is
actually really important because I have
my own intuition we all have our own
intuition that we want to be manifested
in those notes and those hunches and and
and so we want to do the work we want to
show that we're doing the work as well
but we are look I mean we're still only
a few years really into the experiment
and you know things are tracking well
for sure but it is about bringing on
people who also fit into that culture
and and we've really I mean though I I
always go back to this is gonna be very
controversial but I always go back to
sports metaphors for this stuff and and
I do appreciate the system mindset of
béla checks Patriots and I will see
how they do in a post Brady era but but
I do appreciate the mindset of finding
people regardless of sort of talents or
egos or skills that just need to be able
to fit in a system and if they don't you
know but by but I think I think there's
a way venture has been done historically
and I think folks who have come up with
that mindset have not well we just we
haven't even had them be a part of the
team and be a part of the org because we
just knew it's not a fit for us we would
rather find people who are expert so
like Brett Wright has founding
experience has massive technical
experience just just personally
fascinated with and and pretty deep on
all things crypto did not have a
background of early stage investing
maybe a couple angel investments when he
joined us a few years ago but like
that's the part that we can train up
like that's the part where you just got
to get your reps in you you see you be
in enough deals meetings you see enough
of this stuff you start to see the
trends that's just ours and Gary and I
put in a ton of hours doing angel
investing and YC investing and so what
we need are the raw materials of do you
have the expertise do you have the like
can you sit with a founder for 30
minutes and that founder is like oh holy
[ __ ] that was really valuable if you
check those boxes we can build up the
reps on the early stage side and I mean
you know a company like bison trails
which is doing very well right that was
a deal that Brett sourced in part
because of the reputation he's built
over the last few years in crypto but
then also the fact that he could sit
with those founders who want to talk to
him and say yeah this is real and and
and and source that and identify that
and find that and and I just like having
I I we're still early in it but having
this system mentality and being able to
get all the benefits of software which
is the structured data that I mean we
have you can find notes from the first
time you met a founder three years ago
know exactly what you were thinking as
well as like how you rated that
interaction one to five and see which of
your assumptions were wrong and which
right and every vote not just the score
but also how you qualify it so that we
can always be learning and letting
suffer to the hard part of like
basically remembering things and helping
us identify trends so I I'm cautiously
optimistic
it's funny how software does a better
job of remembering things in the human
brain right yeah no I look and more
importantly it's transferable knowledge
like I if so I don't want to ever have
to remember that I just had actually I
don't want to ever have to remember that
we had this interview like I do I don't
I don't want to purge it from my brain
but I I should need to remember it it
will live in structured data in software
that will forever be searchable so that
some intern in two years will have a
record of it that they can search for
they don't need to slack me and be like
hey Lexus you know pop you ever you ever
done that podcast they don't they should
that's a waste of my time it's a waste
of their time they should be able to run
that query in folio which our internal
software and see the entire history of
that relationship in those notes all
those things cuz it's just not worth
it's not worth remembering
and it's also inefficient because it's
still locked in my brain I don't want it
locked in my brain I want to locked in
to a broader network than anyone can
search into but anyone in our in our
trust group in our in our company can
search so you guys are capitalists
why not license it to either other firms
[Music]
we've been asked that we have been asked
that mostly by LPS I don't know I don't
know how I mean competitive firms
probably wouldn't I wish they could come
and come ask it's okay but well one I
don't want to be in the business of like
I I don't want to be a business of
having cost customers for software
anymore it's really nice to only build
software for like a couple dozen people
as opposed to hundreds of millions of
people it's so much better and and I
know ultimately I also think that it
won't work as well for other orgs unless
they
really build their culture for it from
day one like I heard enough horror
stories of larger orgs trying to
implement some great software solution
and there's no participation there's no
one willing to do it because they've
just had so much inertia that it would
take a massive cultural change to
actually get the orgs to use it but for
up-and-coming orgs yeah maybe there's a
business and a viability there but I
don't want to be a business yeah what uh
what's the biggest mistake that you
think you've made in building
initialized or like the biggest lesson
you learned from when you started till
now biggest lesson learned the oh oh
that's okay yeah so the the at the end
of the day because we're doing such
early stage investing the ownership
sizes were something that you know even
at the start of modern initialized we
weren't ambitious enough with what we
were targeting and we're I mean we're
leading seed rounds now and I I knew in
my heart I knew at the start of
initialised that we could do that but we
weren't we didn't execute on that and
and I think I think part of it was just
not wanting to miss right higher
concentration just inevitably means
you're gonna have to be right more
because you're gonna get fewer chances
but but have I wish I had that
confidence at the start of it or at
least started yeah at least more
confidence in that regard because we
would have targeted more ownership
earlier but the good news is we've we've
increased that with every fund and we're
in a better place now but that was the
big like math lesson especially because
we knew we were doing the work like we
knew we were providing value because our
investors were our founders were telling
us like wow you're doing like you all
are way more helpful than our lead
investors we heard that enough times
that we were just like why are we just
doing this why we're doing this work to
help someone else and and so that was
the number one definitely the biggest
lesson yeah and I guess did you that
really get hit home because you saw the
math play out like after a couple of
years you actually said hey wait a
second we own way less of that do all
the dilution and we wanted to or what up
the conversations with the founders it
was both
we had an inkling
over time as founders would report back
like hey you know this is more helpful
than our lead investors and then a few
years out were like we'll wait ok the
founders are telling us that we're doing
the work and providing you know
providing value but we're actually doing
the work and we're not getting rewarded
for it but we could be and why not solve
that problem so we we solve that problem
but that was that's definitely the first
biggest mistake yeah one of my favorite
questions to ask especially early stage
investors that come from the operator
side is do you have one hilarious story
early on when you met with the more
institutional LPS where you guys just
walked out of a meeting you're like well
that either didn't go well or you guys
just kind of laugh about now and say
like remember when X happened don't say
who it is yeah it is we had I almost
feel a little bad and in so I'm gonna
the story is actually not that great but
the macro story is one or actually feel
a little sympathetic which is these
professionals like just default assume
they're smart competent hard-working
people they have to look and evaluate so
many different asset classes and tech
venture is still such a small part
like I mean globally in terms of dollars
like we're nothing right but it's
obviously the most exciting and the best
but it's it's it's got this black box
where I can just I can see them getting
hoodwinked by people who do like I have
no respect for whatsoever just because
they don't know it's a small percentage
of the portfolio so there's not that
much downside and you know especially on
the early stage you don't have a lot of
signal right you don't have years worth
of data this is just a weird very weird
asset class and and so I just I think
the times when I when we walked out of
those meetings just shaking our heads it
was usually because those investors just
didn't know what real was and and maybe
they just didn't appreciate co-founding
and you know turning around reddit maybe
they just didn't appreciate
our track record of early stage
investing maybe they just maybe they
just didn't get why I mean we were fair
I think we're still I don't look as
young now but but fairly young looking
folks were trying to start a VC firm
because they were used to seeing sort of
stately or older folks coming in the
door I don't know but I do I mean I
remember being asked like hammered on
valuations as if this was like value
investing 101 and I'm like at the end of
the day to like it doesn't really matter
like we need percentage ownership like
this is super early stage investing
we're making up valuations most of the
time anyway because there isn't revenue
so like I mean come on okay but but they
were I think they were new to the asset
class one of the things somewhere along
the way there we learned was to ask
early even before the intro like what
what's your experience with venture
investing what's your experience with
early-stage venture investing in
particular because you can run into some
folks nuts I mean these days less so but
certainly in was it 11 or 12 when we
were first talking to folks about
initialized like there were there were
plenty folks who just had family office
types especially just had no idea what
the asset class was about yeah you know
everything looks like a nail and you got
your hammer
we'll get the crypto there's a lot of
parallels there yes very very good we
before we get to crypto sarena there's
people that's all people wanted to talk
about and they're like reddit whatever I
always laugh because every time that a
polina does anything on the internet and
I'm around everyone they say [ __ ] about
hurting I'm like wait a minute like
she's the star right and I feel like so
when I saw the questions on Twitter one
of them was people were basically asking
you got to tell the story about wearing
the Dare shirt to the tennis match
because that's probably that's an
all-time move I I think it's really
important to acknowledge all of the harm
that the DARE program
as well as the war against drugs did on
a generation and and I just chose that
day to wear that shirt to remind
everyone of that speaking of the stately
venture capitalist you're getting
conditioned listen you just happened to
wear this shirt no problem nor a total
coincidence another question this is a
polina question is what was it like
going to the Royal Wedding and and talk
about the socks I Wow y'all are going in
today
alright I mean I was a history major
right so I just loved I especially loved
the fact that I felt like I was like it
I was a part of history in this very
historical setting you know I I was
grateful to be there had a great time
war US flag socks that I made sure the
camera saw as we were doing our little
walk
I don't know hopefully that was there
was just the right amount of civil
disobedience right IIIi really
appreciate a number of these things that
people brought up because I feel like it
is reddit in real life right like just
just enough of seriousness there's just
enough up kind of the trolling and like
we just want you to know we could be
disobedient if we wanted to be yeah I
guess I'll forever be the the sort of
the I guess on some level always do the
reddit co-founder in my heart and last
the last sarena question is you are
married to probably one of if not the
greatest athlete of all time
you drew that probably nonsense have you
ever beat her at anything athletic like
racing to the car jumping jacks tennis
anything never tennis come on be
realistic I've never I've literally
never played tennis in my life so it's
actually very very fortuitous I didn't
even think it was a real sport until we
started dating and I was like okay it's
real sport now I actually I love it it
is such an intense sport I've grew up
playing team sports my whole life and so
I never appreciated solo sports and in
my household like football basketball
were the only two sports so I was
ignorant
and the amount of mental and physical
strength it takes to play professional
tennis I mean it's it's that I would say
I put it up against like UFC boxing
those two others is like the only other
in terms of mental and physical extreme
cuz you're alone you are alone out there
and the physical exertion and the more
important the mental exertion on top of
that that separates the Great's from
everyone else is just next-level but
I've never played it never gonna play it
I'm actually Philippian Olympia if she's
into it then I can be a really good like
baby instructor mm-hmm until she gets
like actually capable and then Serena
will take over and you know and then
I'll play a couple matches with Olympia
until she's like five and then she'll
watch me when I was a kid my mom for
whatever reason took meet a couple of my
brothers and said you can go to this
tennis camp and we played baseball
football basketball right and I remember
we made it through one day of the camp
and they asked us not to come back
because halfway through the dearies well
we just realized like look we're not
good at this this like takes actual
skill so instead when they hit the ball
to us let's just see who can hit it the
farthest out of yes yes and I feel like
that's kind of like if you don't grow up
with the skill of you know learning
tennis that's pretty much what everyone
else does just hit as hard as you can
and just hope it goes somewhere near
where it's supposed to ya know that's
that's the realness and so definitely I
would never try to play tennis against
their physical their --zz she I have
some advantages based on one my height
and my size as well as like those
childhood sports so like I remember the
first time I saw Serena shoot a basket
or try to and now now it was that is
that is God clearly being like that's
what you get for talking about your wife
playing basketball I got talking to Gary
about why this happens because this
weekend will be an edited all right but
seriously what anyway
but yeah she's not not good at all at
basketball so like there are things if
we were playing a game a horsehide
washer or one on one but like this is
not it's not fair because you would not
take I don't know you would not put a
formula the the best formula on race car
on a demolition derby track and expect
it to do well and like so yeah so there
are some things where I and it's
actually it's especially nice because I
get to feel like I beat an Olympian
which I'm deluding myself entirely right
it's it's nonsense but in that moment it
feels nice and it's also quite
humanizing for her to I think I mean
she's obviously amazing the the reality
is her moments of normalcy only make her
moments of greatness even more
impressive like she's still a klutz
she's still her baking's actually gotten
really good recently if you seen the
sooner all updates like she's still
terrible at shooting a free throw and
those things actually make all the other
stuff even more exceptional and it's
also a good reminder that like all of us
are are with our flaws and but
nonetheless I mean yeah she's the goat
so I don't hear any of this I don't hear
this this one of I will defend that one
of my day I love it
you've you guys have obviously made a
ton of investments across a whole
spectrum of of trends and industries
what specifically are you guys looking
at right now as whether it's kind of
coming out of the co big crisis stuff or
just before we went into this this is
the thing that you guys are interested
in I it's gonna look prophetic but it's
not we we ended up I mean company is
like Roe and true pill in telehealth are
doing very well and poised to continue
to do so in in the wake of this and
excuse me it's not a I think it is that
is one industry that I think is is going
to be very good for business as well as
for society because what people are
realizing is that
at a minimum they can get great they can
get a great form of health care on
demand for you know nothing thanks to
this technology thanks to smartphones
and at a minimum that helps reduce yet
I'd be remiss if we didn't talk about
crypto derp and all this man I obviously
you know we were early investors in
coinbase
that has done well talking about that
deal you found through Y Combinator yeah
and and actually this is I mean this is
like initialized lore so you know then
we were basing this Geary to his credit
was was early and dabbling in Bitcoin I
would just see it talked about all the
time on reddit and I was like all right
well if enough people on reddit are
engaged and interested in talking about
it there's at least this early adopter
signal which is powerful especially for
something as technological as
cryptocurrency and we we basically and I
remember there's an email exchange where
we were like all these valuations a
little steep but thankfully we were just
like that doesn't matter if this if this
is right
this will create such a new economy and
they will be like the premier Bank for
the west of of crypto like that's it's
valuable but the part that's initialized
lore was and I forget I think Bitcoin
had jumped to maybe like four or five
dollars and they were running out of
working capital coinbase was every
morning by like 9:00 a.m. just because
they had so many people on the platform
and and Brian and Gary were having one
of their sort of regular like coaching
sessions slash lunch sessions like every
month and Brian was like yeah this is my
problem and Gary was like that is a good
problem to have we can help and so we
gave them a round of funding to help
sort of bridge them to the series a
which I think USV ended up doing and you
know that that investment alone was
incredibly valuable for the firm even
more so than the initial check because
we basically doubled down when we saw
that there was real real demand here and
yeah it's it's done well for us and so
we've been thoughtful
about it we didn't get caught up into
the ico craze nonsense which was good
really just treated every crypto
investment as like a Delaware C Corp and
and really we're looking for the same
product things that we look for in any
company and and a lot of it was around
infrastructure whether it was like coin
tracker for helping with crypto taxes
bison shows which obviously was the most
recent investment about running secure
infrastructure on multiple blockchains
I guess technically atomic loans is the
most recent which we did together which
like is an economy of lending that just
couldn't even have been conceived of
some five years ago and and what's
exciting now is that there are enough
sort of incumbents in the space
especially on the mining side with
Bitcoin that like there's clear economic
need here and let's use software to fill
it and so we're still I I don't know
when it's time to call crypto spring
because I keep talking about it and I
just want like I I think the winter was
so important to get rid of the
charlatans and not all of them but be
able to get rid of a lot of them and get
people refocused on solving real
problems and and actually help bringing
this into the mainstream the part that
still confounds me is that even during
these times of volatility where the
markets don't make sense and the
printing machine goes BRR how does one
actually say that because I just know
the meme and I just read the text but I
don't actually so you ready i I don't
know if this is correct but I literally
walk around now whenever I see a
headline I just go oh that makes more
sense than my Burrell Ike it's cold I
don't know if it's right but I just for
whatever reason decided that's what I'm
gonna say no that why because I don't
know what of money I realize I don't
know what a Monti money printing machine
actually sounds like but it probably
seems more like that one the dexterity
of that one but like that it still it
confounds me because I still I mean I'm
still long I still hold Bitcoin some
aetherium and some other
god dammit you know I think the video
just went out because they don't want to
hear about any Bitcoin the Fed is angry
at me
I actually think this might have
overheated okay hon I'm gonna I got a
new plan I got a new plan
let me get my mccrane cup be a scene
here poor baby
you running hot alright I've got some
serious feedback though for Gary tan
when we talk about this setup I don't
know how it keeps it he probably he
probably has a nice temperature in his
home got that 90 degrees South Florida
weather and I was trying to keep okay
how bad is this background noise now the
AC is gone oh well see I should do this
from the start okay but I keep I keep
waiting for Bitcoin to surge again
because it feels like the this can't I
mean I think it's important I do think
it's really important we're making these
cash infusions and I wish they got they
got two Americans and the small
businesses that needed it not like say
Airlines but uh but I just can't help
but feel like this will just further
expedite the growth and acceptance of
cryptocurrency broadly but but
especially Bitcoin and that the trick is
like is it now too much of a just kind
of investment or has the infrastructure
not been built yet to make it really
seamless to spend spend spend it as
easily as like USD but I'm still like
the the we're still making investments
on the infrastructure side we just
announced Brett was the lead partner on
the series a for a horizon which is it's
aetherium backed but they're building
the game technology for digital assets
like a playing card in a video game you
actually own right this is this was so
appealing to me as someone who grew up
playing magic as well as spell fire the
D&D knockoff of magic and then
eventually hearthstone and then looking
at the fact that like I spend all this
money of digital goods that I don't
actually own like this just makes
sense for a generation of gamers who are
spending real money now if if we were in
World of Warcraft
going on eBay to buy or sell characters
or or actually buy gold from gold
farmers overseas remember that and then
having them meet us in the digital world
to arrange the drop-off if that was
happening
a decade ago then there's clear right if
there's if there's that level of
contraband and sort of a legal black
market happening then then surely if you
bring it into a frictionless like great
market environment it's gonna thrive and
that's the bet there with Sky Weaver at
least as their proof of concept for
horizon but I I really believe this
infrastructure is getting built now and
has been built for the last few years by
highly technical product minded founders
who are thinking about user experience
we're thinking about building things
people actually want and now it'll be
another five really it'll be another
five years as we watch the fruits of
that get built and scale which will be
exciting I mean I you know I really
trusted you Sony I trusted you to make a
product that would not die okay so on
the crypto side obviously you guys read
it cuz announced or the years what when
he token well here's what I'll say is I
probably more than most understand
there's certain things you can say you
can't say exception maybe just talk
about crypto within the reddit system
why something other than Bitcoin it was
Bitcoin ever considered they're just
kind whatever you're comfortable saying
there so I I have to unfortunately keep
very mum about this what I can say is
the thing you know we we had had reddit
the company had had some forays into
crypto and some of your Twitter people
had remarked on this when I came back in
14 as executive chair there were some
forays into it but it was mostly still
research we had much more pressing
things to handle at that point
much more pressing things and like for
instance we didn't have a mobile team or
plan or anything like it was more
important in 2014 that ready to have a
mobile app and a mobile website and that
we were building towards that for
instance but I have always believed the
long-term value of Reddit is not gonna
come from traditional from advertising
it will come from the fact that we've
already done the hardest part we have
managed to build a platform that handles
tens of thousands of communities and
hundreds of millions of users who truly
have a sense of community and belonging
with one another and we know and a lot
of this was inadvertent frankly like we
didn't have a grand vision in five to do
this but we watched it happen and I had
a front-row seat as we were like I was
the first community manager for our
first ten communities I would just post
links under different user names and
moderate submissions so everyone stayed
on sort of task and subject and we've
watched whether it's digital goods in
gaming right I want to buy a skin so I
look nice for myself and for my friends
and for strangers right there's no I
mean there's a small tribe there of like
people you know and then people you'll
randomly sort of shoot and walk away
from in the video game but on reddit
people are people will buy pizzas for
strangers people have such a much
stronger tribal spirit and community
spirit that if you could take the best
lessons learned from digital goods and
gaming things like tipping on Twitch or
patreon and provide a very seamless
digital transaction for that it will
happen it will happen a lot and like
even Awards the first version of Reddit
Awards
I'm modeled after the awards at the end
of Goldeneye where you have some that
made sense and then you have these
others like random like RC p90 award I
forget there was some random and like we
didn't really have I don't even know if
we ever looked it up we would have used
HotBot I don't know we wouldn't have
googled it back then but like we we
liked as gamers we really like this idea
of oh you get this award if you
you certain good things over the course
of a day and that was just for you on
and I was like 2006 so before any of
this award stuff gamification any of
that stuff was a thing we did it just
because we were copying Goldeneye and
what I wish we had done was double down
on it back then because what we're
already seeing now even with small
modest improvements towards that users
love giving them to one another they
love subreddits communities love
creating them it reinforces this
tribalism and the more that we can do to
help communities and users strengthen
their relationships to one another and
make money in a way that they're happy
with like the more we win and and it
just seems like a logical transition
then if we know I just gave you the
horizon experience with Skye Weaver
right if we know this stuff works where
you don't have any ownership whatsoever
and it's a massive industry and growing
it reasons it reasons to be that if you
allow for a kind of ownership and and a
kind of decentralization to it that
people would do it even more because
they can feel all the fields we get when
we you know take a cup and say hey do
you want this cup here you go
so and then may not not have this cup
anymore of course and so I wish I could
tell you more about it I love the fact
that there is this much energy here and
and I do think long-term a big part of
my job on the board especially right now
while you know Redditt traffic like
every UGC site is booming we can
reasonably all expect marketing dollars
to soften and and so now is the time for
companies like reddit to double down on
revenue streams that are like this that
are a creative that are things that
build on community dynamics that
actually add value to everyone involved
and and and as xu the sort of
traditional models of marketing or at
least you know remove our reliance on
them as a business yeah I love it
there's a lot of questions about
you know you kind of have this great
journey to where you sit today but early
on you know it was like hey look we
wanted a company we kind of have an idea
oh that idea sucks okay like here's
another one right what's your advice
right now to college kids or kind of
kids coming out of high school
especially given the macro economy that
the virus and Ralph you know what skills
should they be developing and kind of
how should they be thinking about their
careers you know over the next 2-3 years
sure I I mean I realized a lot of people
watching this are like this guy this
guy's married to Serena Williams this
guy co-founded reddit and initialized
really really first investor in corn
base what and and I get that and I
appreciate that and I want I want you to
take away from that that uh there is
very little that one can plan for in
life and so my guiding principle would
be actually was supposed to do a
graduation speech that I think is moving
digitally now so this is this is a good
kind of beta test for it focus on the
things you can control and and and work
as hard as you can to improve on those
things get better at those things and
then spend as little time as you can
Wehling other things you can't and
that's sort of a general kind of kovat
economic macro situation there but but
in particular if there are things that
you love doing that don't feel like work
but are viable things in a new economy
do more of them really really focus on
those things because that is the best
path to a great career one that gives
you fulfillment whether or not that ends
up being you know fabulous riches is not
as important as like having the
fulfillment of a job that is not gonna
get automated away and that will give
you satisfaction and and provide for you
know hopefully a family or just for
yourself
that's the stuff I would focus on and I
think there will be a generation of high
school students that will now think
twice or their parents will also think
twice about taking on the student loan
debt of going to a lot of universities I
know I don't think the top tier schools
will have as much to worry about because
there's
still so much credentialism and network
and brand and whatnot but there's a lot
of schools that don't this is gonna
sound terrible but don't have a really
unique value proposition that don't have
a clearly articulated value for the very
very expensive tuition and the crushing
inescapable student loan debt it would
give that but I hope we can learn from
what I think were well-intentioned
mistakes encouraging everyone to go to
college as a path up and instead say
alright let's have a critical serious
look at what you enjoy doing what you
want to do and consider an option that
just makes the most sense and so like
I've tweeted about this and one of your
folks asked about it I would love to see
a reimagining of trade schools a kind of
I think part of its rebranding it just
simply like having a kind of you know we
we were early investors in General
Assembly which was one of the early kind
not quite coding boot camp but type of
sort of like a community college 2.0
with very modern skills being taught by
actual practitioners subversion and
beautifully branded and just felt very
premium what is the general assembly of
skilled labor
what is the version of that for welders
of these professions that we know are in
tremendous demand for the average age of
the people doing it is I think in the
50s maybe like upper 40s but this is a
generation that's getting ready to
retire with with no real replacement but
for jobs that are still desperately
needed and even in a time of increased
automation there are so many tasks that
just won't be audited audit automated
away easily because of all the physical
and mental complexity and creativity
required to solve them and and that's
the fact that like building a robot that
can come in to this office and go figure
out what's wrong with my toilet is
really really hard it's really hard and
m4 for the foreseeable future at least
as I believe it plumbers will not get
replaced the welders Rumaki replaced
there will be software and systems to
make their jobs less repetitive
right there just like we do an
initialized we're gonna automate away
the things that require memory like
extreme memory or planning or scheduling
like the things that humans just suck at
and don't get fulfillment from anyway
and let them focus on the parts that are
creative that are physical and sort of
very specific that are valuable and and
so I think I think we need to tell a
generation of kids look if you're gonna
end up just being a history major at the
University of blah because you want to
spend four years you know going to
college because that's the thing to do
reconsider it and and if you like
working with your hands or if you have
if you have interests and passions
outside of like this sort of general
like oh yeah I want to go to college to
have fun and party there should be way
more affordable paths to getting a
really valuable education even in the
new economy and then the like the cheat
code which is the thing I mean I went to
82 universities when my book came out in
2013
82 universities across the u.s. and
Canada telling people if you're at all
interested because you're already in
college now like if you're at all
interested in learning to code do it
please like like just take the class
even if you don't like it great you are
exposed to it that is the cheat code for
the new economy if you want the like it
is not
I guess unlike a cheat code it is not
easy to accomplish it takes work it is
not a trivial skill to learn let alone
to master but like please like that is a
path into a kind of job security that is
if you enjoy it incredibly fulfilling
both spiritually as well as financially
and and now that has expanded beyond
engineering to product design we're
seeing even amidst all the layoffs right
now in for instance the bay area so much
of this talent is getting scooped up by
the folks who are sitting at the table
with a munch chips who have the cash and
now have an opportunity to hire even
more great talent and so you know I it's
unfortunately it is not as simple as
saying like do what you love like that's
that's just irrational I don't think
great advice but putting more of a point
on it if there are things you really
enjoy doing where you can lose hours
working on them and they don't feel like
work um and they fit those criteria that
we just talked about where it's the kind
of work that's not gonna get automated
away like that is probably a really good
path for you to keep going down and and
I think remote learning all this stuff
is gonna see a huge bump coming out of
this I've got a friend actually he he
started buying up and kind of rolling up
electric electricians simply because he
said not only our electricians not gonna
get automated away he goes the schools
are so bad that we're actually churning
out less of them and there fo become
more valuable you know over the next
mile in 15 years
so if I if I manage to fund trade school
2.0 then I'm actually hurting your buddy
he'll be fine alright he will be just
fine but we need we we so need this and
and I think one of the good byproducts
of the isolationism that I think we'll
see in the next five to ten years is it
will recreate or it'll resurrect a self
reliance culture which I do think is a
good thing and I think with that will
come more scrutiny on oh yeah look at
all this infrastructure we've let go to
waste here in the greatest country on
Earth
right and that will that will reshift
the mindset around a lot of these trades
that will that will change some of the
broader culture around it and help do
the help do part of the work but we
still need that reinvention of the
actual education programs to your point
but I do think that's a silver lining I
I it it does hurt my heart that we will
see such a big shift inward in the next
five to ten years because I really do
I'm the child of an immigrant my mom was
technically undocumented for three years
because she overstayed her visa which is
how most undocumented immigrants get
into the country b-t-dub
you know she overstayed her visa for a
few years and thankfully ice didn't toss
her out and she married my dad and while
I'm here but like it does hurt
my heart because I really do appreciate
so much that we gain from this open flow
of information and ideas and humans I
really like our food in America would be
pretty wack as if England is any
indication right England benefit of UK
benefited tremendously from a flow of
immigrants who really leveled up the
cuisine there like if nothing else my
fellow Americans you should appreciate
immigration for the fact that it has
made our food so great here in America
and and so yeah there's there's a part
of me that definitely it's gonna sting
to see this closeness that I think we're
undeniably gonna be heading toward the
next five ten years I hope we can make
up enough of that with things digitally
I mean right I think this will also
ironically then give rise to more and
more of these decentralized type
networks that can thanks to you know in
in most countries that can transcend
sort of national blocks but uh look I
just want I want to see the best ideas
win and I know that the best ideas don't
all come from the United States and I
know that opportunity is not universally
distributed even in our own country and
I just want better things and so that's
the that's this thing of it but I do
think one of the silver linings of that
self-reliance will will actually make us
stronger as a country three questions to
wrap up with and you could ask me one to
ended absolutely anything you you are a
new dad what is the the one thing that
you either enjoy or have learned that
you did not expect before you became a
dad well you've got to listen to my
podcast business dad season one is out
now no uh the biggest thing that I've
learned it put into perspective how how
I don't see how horribly I lived my life
before I found out I was gonna be a dad
but like at 34 35 I found out I was
gonna be a dad and and I just it it was
perspective building man I really I
wanted to get better I wanted to be
better about the
that I ate the things that I drank
things that I smoked the amount of
exercise I did the just taking care of
myself my even seeing a doctor like I I
felt a new appreciation for my own
mortality and a semi disgust at how
little I cared and how much I lived for
myself up until that point and and so I
I know in so many ways it has made me a
better person because I now evaluate
everything through that and and through
that legacy and through that role model
that I'm providing to her and I'm still
still messing up all the time but as a
North Star it has been so much more
fulfilling
then I mean I felt I felt really great
about starting reddit I felt really
great about all the work we've done with
initialize like there's so many ways
that we keep score in business that are
all kind of made-up but they're good
we're competitive people we need that
stimulation right but it put all of it
into such a perspective or I was like
this is this little person she she
matters more than any of this other
stuff this family unit matters so much
and and I think it has helped me it's
definitely made me a better man and I
wish I could say just meeting and
marrying my wife did that and that
helped it absolutely did but not even
it's just a very different level I I'm
sure she would say the same thing like
yeah meeting you Alexis marrying Alexis
was great but the thing that really
changes everything was was was was
having Olympia so I'm not encouraging
everyone to go out and make babies right
now though there there will definitely
be some quarantine kids by December
that's for sure but but I do I'm so
grateful for the opportunity to be her
dad it's awesome that's awesome I think
people can see it right just kind of the
way that you act and think it's really
cool I mean I still do dumb stuff let's
be clear like and that's the other thing
too I I also get really self-conscious
about the fact that I am NOT a perfect
dad like and I don't I we we all have
myself included we all have stories that
we present to the world and I should
just post more photos of Olympia being
sad she's not as cute of course cuz she
says she makes a face though that's kind
of cute cuz she's like her face gets
really fly
and it's her sad crying face and it's
it's it's adorable but right I hope I
hope the takeaway can be and I should do
a better job of this with the pod - I
hope that takeaway is like look this is
a work in progress
and I just even from talking all these
different other business dad's the best
the common thread between all of them is
is they're all very accepting of the
fact that they're just trying to figure
it out - and and they're picking and
choosing and learning and adapting and
and you know we're we're screwing up all
the time just like in our startups we're
just hoping the trajectory is up and to
the right with our children - what's
your favorite book ever other than the
one you wrote my favorite book ever
okay the controversial one that I really
I enjoyed a lot more than I thought I
would was um winner winners take all
which is not my favorite book of all
time at all but I really love the books
that I've read in the last like year I
really appreciated that one for giving
me a dose and a perspective that I think
I rarely get and I want I and I don't
know how this is gonna turn out because
I know I'm sort of responsible for this
with reddit but social media has done an
amazing job letting us find our tribes
as well as discover new tribes who don't
even know we had and I think overall
that is amazing right we get to learn
about crypto together with people from
all over the world who humbled us and
teach us and oh that's awesome it also
means it's easier than ever and this is
like version 2 of like the filter bubble
that they were talking about years ago
they it makes it easier than ever for us
to then isolate ourselves and not want
to be subjected to ideas that make us
angry or at least challenge our
worldviews and then there's a fine line
there cuz I think there are some ideas
where it's perfectly reasonable be like
that's a terrible idea
like that's a bad thing but but there's
always this nuance that I worry will get
lost as we get better and better at
finding our tribes and so I try to make
an effort to find and read things that
challenge it I don't do a great job of
it but I do from
time to find that and you know when I
think of when I think of like a
universal thing like book that I
actually would recommend to anyone you
know one of my favorites one of my
favorites might be this book drive about
human motivation and incentive just
because it's guided a lot of the ways
that I think about product as well as
community which are the things that
everyone seems to ask me about when it's
about investing or startup advice and
human incentive is still something that
we don't fully understand maybe we never
will but I'm just I'm awed by it because
on the one hand sometimes it's very
rational other times it is incredibly
irrational but there is actually some
reason to the irrational stuff and I
think all the times that I have had
success as an investor especially an
early stage really just comes from
paying attention to these trends and and
being a better observer than like
prognosticator like I don't think we're
particularly good at predicting the
future and I don't know we can't do it
in a bubble but if you can get really
good at identifying trends and looking
for signal amidst a lot of noise and you
know reading read it every day for a
decade and a half has helped you can
find it and I mean that's the the magic
right now is kovat has exposed the
strength of the fifth estate where so
thomas carlyle history major right right
he talks about the for the state is
media being a check against the three
estates the three branches of government
both government and the media showed a
failure to really prepare us for kovat
19 and and those the two institutions
that historically like balance each
other out and have all sort of the the
trust of the nation in one one pocket or
another but but it was the 50 state
social media that actually really was
ahead of this I mean that's that's the
reason I like I I felt like Cassandra
talked
to investors or portfolio founders in
January some of whom right didn't really
believe the advice because they were
trusting one of those other estates and
and that's only because I followed the
right people on Twitter it's only
because I followed the right people and
I had a couple partners at the firm who
are also tuned in but what does this new
world look like as the Fifth Estate gets
stronger and stronger and as individuals
you all are each one of you are
developing your own media brands and and
and I don't know what the accounting of
that is gonna be but there's real value
in being able to show being right early
in a way that like you know a hundred
years ago it was subscriber counts of a
newspaper what does that look like now I
don't think it's necessarily YouTube
followers perhaps there's a great
blockchain based way to to to show this
I don't know but I'm excited for it I'm
also clueless as to how it's gonna turn
out because as humans we just I mean
this is a little sapiens sign I'm doing
the VC thing but like we just really
don't have a context biologically for
this much data like our tribes were
really so they were the people we could
walk around or walk to for a long time
and and we only got mass communication
one last hundred years travel 50 years
like we're still figuring this stuff out
and now we can go online and I can see
what someone had for breakfast in Seoul
I can I can see real-time images for how
you know they're handling kovat in
Mumbai I can see opinions from literally
all over the world in real-time and I
think Paul was prescient when he said
there's there needs to be a front page
of the Internet I think reddit has now
built multiple front pages for the
multiple Internet's the sort of multiple
tribes but I wouldn't say that that is
the accounting of the internet what is
that gonna be because the answer for
that is gonna I think be really valuable
in years to come because especially if
you're in the business of trying to make
money or trying to understand where
the future is headed like it is gonna be
really valuable to know where that
signal is and I don't know how that's
gonna play out but speaking of humans
third question are you believe in aliens
I think the real I think it is possible
like are you asking me do I think that
they visited not was a ninja yeah no I
think if the universe is infinite then
which I believe then I think that it is
plausible that there is alien life it
might not be impressive again I mean
you're asking a tech guy this question
but like I don't think it could be I
think it could be like a you know a
single-celled organism but it's still an
alien do I think it's like a xenomorph
from alien hopefully not but maybe but I
sorry I guess the real answer is I don't
know but I could imagine so yes yeah the
thing that's terrifying though right is
if they can we've now explored enough of
our galaxy that if they can get here
then their [ __ ] is gonna be magic
relative to what we can comprehend and
so at this point I'd rather not find out
unless we're the ones visiting them I
think that's the best way to look at it
is at least your honor the people who
usually invade some other place or
usually end up being the victor right
now let me check this out right
I wish and there might still be a chance
but I really wish Kovach 19 would be our
like Independence Day moment as a world
because this virus doesn't care about
any of us you does not care about how
much money you make or your race or your
generate doesn't care about anything
just wants to make you sick and make
other people sick I really hoped it
could be the Independence Day moment I'm
looking for the Jeff Goldblum and Will
Smith to save us or some way help us put
aside our differences in unify and we're
seeing in pockets but maybe you know the
special effects budget of
at 19 is just not great so it's not very
compelling go get to see giant
spaceships hovering over massive cities
but I wish we could think that way I
really do because I hate kovat 19 one
question you have for me to finish this
up what what made you want to invest in
atomic loans I'm just a big believer now
I'm gonna notice a couple of times so
like the whole idea of you've got sound
money in Bitcoin or at least the
properties of sound money but all the
infrastructure for the most part is
sexualised around it so whether it's the
coin basis to Gemini's the flock flies
etc some of it were invested in some of
or not if you look in the like ether
etherium world you get what they're
trying to make money like EFA's money
meme and and they're trying to do it but
the infrastructure is decentralized so
like you almost get like decentralized
sound money that has centralized
infrastructure but then you get
decentralized infrastructure with
something that looks kind of like a fiat
currency to something thief and so you
gotta bring those two decentralized
components together the money and the
infrastructure the big question is do
you bring Bitcoin to the eath world or
do you bring Defy to the Bitcoin
ecosystem and I tend to think you're
gonna bring the infrastructure to
Bitcoin
rather than bring Bitcoin to to eath
highly controversial I've had a million
people come on and you know [ __ ] and
complain and basically say that yeah I'm
an idiot and all stuff but that's just
kind of my general thought process and
then ended up you guys were investing
and made sense right on well excellent
I'm glad glad to be cooking with you in
the kitchen on that absolutely where do
you want people to go to find out more
about you or initialize
you can follow me on the Twitter at
Alexis Ohanian or Instagram if you're
into that I assume Twitter's gonna be
the move for for your crowd and then
they should go to initialize comm
obviously if they want to learn more
about the firm that's it I don't have a
SoundCloud not yet awesome man listen I
appreciate doing this is a ton of
a lot of people wanted to kind of hear
what you guys are up to and I'm a big
fan obviously anybody starting a company
should should go check you guys out and
then convince you to give them some
money like like atomic loans and many
others right on thank you very much for
having me sorry we can do this in person
but you know so it goes covin sucks yeah
Kovac sucks hashtag Cove it sucks all
right thanks man
likewise I